hey hey hey hey hey hey
meme review
i'm back in the land where the toilet
seat isn't heated
uk sucks there's a couple memes we need
to go through
i literally landed three hours ago i
need to make
video how else would they know what
memes and what to think about them
first off it's spooktober which can only
mean one thing
creative original memes spooked over
put a skeleton in your meme and bam
that wasn't funny but it had a skeleton
in it
me going to sleep with 206 bones me
waking up with two other sabbats
there should be girls waking up boys
waking up
right wouldn't that be funnier god i
have to do everything here
it's spooktober so dead memes are extra
spooky
get it he got it one person one person
got it everywhere i go
i see his face everywhere i go
all the memes i watch this film
literally on the plane on the way back
here
and i was so disappointed because this
quote
isn't said at that point in the you
can't just add a text
oh my god i should never watch the
marvel films
now i know all the memes are a lie he
doesn't say it at that point in the film
the meme is ruined delete this meme raid
the vet spooktober
it's october everyone it's spectacular
remember last year when i had all the
math memes and it was so on point with
booktober
i wonder what we're going to get this
year specs back imagine being a ghost
and going all like spec
spec getting her pregnant and running
away staying to help raise the kids
staying for the free calcium
free titty milk thank you
the child supersite separate child
this is my ew sorry too visual i
understand
well enjoy spooktober everyone i hope
you have a blessed month
and these memes of course gets uh
no i'll give it an actual rating spark
whatever you do
do not ask who is joe
[Music]
i'm telling you now as it is i'm telling
you now i'm giving you a fair warning
this is worse than any expectable meme
look what happened to squidward
don't ask who joe is friend spell i
cup me i see you joe
friend who is joe
[Laughter]
who's joe i don't understand
joe mama who is joe
joe mamasa hey babe i'm so sorry
but i think i might have ligma you might
want to get yourself tested
holy sh isn't that like up dog no not
that bad
it's kind of like soccum oh frick how
can you be
such a bofa i know i think i got it from
joe where the hell is joe
we won mr stark we did it
the new language of the gods the
sentence that can destroy anyone
you think you knew them all we'll think
again your mama
don't even try don't even try to write
marzia because i already got her
okay and it was epic she basically went
low dying of ligma i am
that's my geode impression who's joe
i have seen the war of bosnia and as a
result
i am severely dependent on several
opoids
i am good meme very good memes
never ask woman her age a man his salary
a gamer who is joe never do it
stop guys if we can trick ninja
into asking who's joe that'd be epic
troll moment let's start banning all the
mama
[Applause]
so say that okay it really isn't that
funny but i had to bring it up that's my
job
that's the rating that was the rating in
case that was an obvious
next meme i am delirious help me
the meme that just won't die it came
back this uh
last week this last week yes that's the
sentence first with a
what was it like the first guy who did
it must have been like
and then he came back with the fourth
wall breaking thing
where he stared into the camera me in
the middle school looking at my crush
my crush me looks away shyly
but of course it has to go overboard the
entire class
the entire class when i take out my
chewing gum
that's funny because it's relatable like
why do everyone want chum gum so bad
the first guy to make money must have
been like stoinks
epic the first dude to meet medusa was
to be like stones
that's epic relatable as well i like
that
6 a.m close eyes 8 20 so relatable
how does that even work time travel
question mark the news host when their
video calls
are delayed what the first guy
to discover the nether portal must have
been like epic
when you rub your eyes a bit too much
this meme is too relatable it has too
many relatable points
uber driver me
so bad why would this meme go away
why go go away i had enough the first
guy to be cryogenically
frozen will probably be like
please i'm begging i'm backing
i'm begging so up oh god there's more
it's the first guy who wants to break
the fourth wall
we didn't need this no one needed this
little kids
yeah stupid kids i hate them iron atoms
iron atoms in a magnetic field didn't i
literally just make this
v meme yesterday did i not say this you
should have one where it's all the back
head
and then when you flip the magnets
around and
he looks at you okay okay okay a third
panel to this meme iron atoms
in the magnetic field when i flip the
magnet and then you just have the back
over here that's hilarious
you're welcome internet this meme gets
uh
next meme all right gamers this next
meme is the top of the top of the tippy
the top of the titty me i'm so glad that
ad
is over youtube another one there is
no wait that's somebody says there is
another when does he say it
it's when uh oh yeah luke has a sister
that's right
college girl fails a test is there
another way to pass
teacher there is another
me get some 40 on the test teacher the
lowest was 36
me there is another it's just the text
there is another
and that's the punch line over and over
and i kind of feel like
since we know that's going to be the
case every single time it kind of loses
its
point but finishes wiping the last drop
of p
my pp three seconds later there is
another
that's hilarious it's too relatable
why they keep dripping pp why can't and
why when i try to suck up pp the last
remaining it hurt my pp
why don't tell me you never tried it
shut the frick up
shut the frick you never try to suck up
the pp
you never try to suck up the pp tell me
honestly that's what i thought
everyone tried to suck up the pee pee
and then realized it hurt
everyone did science science will never
solve this problem
why they always be dripping i don't
understand it i don't understand
it everyone's focusing about focusing on
cringe environment
environment issues as well i'm sorry
to go on a little rant there me i'm so
glad that
i literally reviewed this keanu reeves
there is two people
in the u.s named keanu reese there's
another keanu reeves
his name must be john wick or something
when your girlfriend says
you can't smash because her hole is
bleeding
there is another girlfriend replies no
not until it's your birthday and then
you'll be like
there is another
and she'd be like no and then you're
like there is another
math teacher you can only solve this
equation
with this method asian kid there is
another
because asian kids are good at math i
didn't want to say it
but i did no there is another
and his name is john cena
i'm sorry to see this meme go because i
thought it had potential with the peepee
bit but it gets an poopy peepee
sorry gamer that sucks next
meme there is still so many girl versus
guy memes
it just doesn't stop so i'm just gonna
keep reviewing them until it's dead
that's what i do i don't know why anyone
is confused girls when they need help
with their crush
how to flirt with guys boys when they
need help with their crush
i invented a magic trick that will get
you laid
that penguins guy looks just like
critical that's crazy
girls i should follow speed regulations
to avoid an accident
boys i paid for the whole speedometers
i'm gonna use the
spin up what
i realize this meme is literally that's
my best literally
it's the nobody meme isn't it a
punchline for nobody nobody
boys right girls during puberty
boys dirty pure birdie i am the milkman
my milk is delicious i don't underst oh
it's another peepee joke girls you're
not gonna understand girls bathroom i
love the boy
who didn't appreciate me and it freaked
me
up boys bathroom
our asses touched the same seat
we are brothers we are brothers i ride
with you
to the end of dawn to the end of times
my ass
brother my heat transferred butt
soldier men don't know what it's like to
feel pain
we give birthday checkmate
ramen image speaks for itself that's the
millennium falcon in lego
dropped on the floor in at least a
thousand pieces you wouldn't understand
possibly any intricacy of what
sort of human suffering this entails i
felt like i needed to tip my fedora
in respect for whoever did this girls
watching story time videos
my psycho ex-boyfriend best friend story
time
boys watching toy time videos i flooded
the toilet in chipotle
that's so cool guys are so epic and
random
girls during workout i need to get that
perfect
buttocks as saren boys during workout i
need to reach that pole before that car
uh or i'll die come on everyone does
this
i don't care if you're a poor girl this
is a universal freaking meme
this is an all-inclusive meme thank you
very much
there's one more girls on halloween
dresses up a slight animal boys on
halloween
oh that ties in with spooktober that's
epic school power goes off
random girl in class why do you have to
scream
cringe all right boy versus girl memes
inclusive
maybe next week maybe boys and girls
needs to rate each other's lairs
like that could be the new meme or
whatever just a thought
finally we had the shepherd betrays in
modern warfare meme
why shepherd why me see that's another
thing girls you will never understand
betrayal like when shepard shot roach
in the end of modern warfare 2. i would
say spoilers but i know you will never
play such an epic game me finds an
eight block diamond or wayne my friend
this is a tough one to review because a
lot of emotions sibling i accidentally
clicked on new game instead of continue
yeah girl boys can't understand how to
feel
god damn it i literally made the joke me
and tears trust me
we know such an epic joke as well girls
when they find a random bag of chips
okay we all get five boys
it's a combined it's a combined meme and
i like it i like it i like it i like it
okay that's it that that was it uh
do we have time for bonus memes
it's obama's last name care for bin
laden
top comment winter trip to obama
okay okay here you go i know that stock
this one is good all right
we broke up last week bro what
well that sucks
get it he's speaking the language of the
gods
beautiful well that's all the time we
had for bonus memes hope you guys
enjoyed this episode if you did smash
like subscribe to the channel if you
want more content
every single day baby check out
represent.com pewdiepie if
you want to get mad puss smush
and if you're a girl if you just want to
up votes on my reddit
and that's it for me for now i'm going
to go pass out see you gamers next time
bye you haven't
tried tuber simulated seriously after 50
million outros
just download it